welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and John Krasinski
is back as Jack Ryan and the second
season of the Amazon show throughout
this video I'm gonna be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the new release as well as what happens
at the end and where it could lead
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch Jack
Ryan yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for click in
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of Jack Ryan season 2 season 1
of Jack Ryan followed the titular
character tracking down a terrorist
known as the suleiman a villain that was
thought to be the next bin Laden though
Ryan managed to stop him it was due to
underhanded tactics and it was clear
that the shadow recruit was becoming
more involved in the darker side of
special ops in the end Ryan was promoted
to the head of t fed and his colleague
agent Greer
sorry officer Greer was relocated to
Russia season two begins in the South
China Sea with a missile being launched
that contains an unregistered satellite
and it elevates exponentially from there
the second season takes a real turn
early on by not painting out the
villains it's Russia China or even South
Korea but instead by saying that the
threat that we should be worried about
is Venezuela look I didn't believe it
either whilst initially you and the
characters might scoff and think that
the country isn't even worth paying
attention to this pretty much sums up
the entire second season of Jack Ryan
and all of the characters involved have
to fly under the radar throughout in
order to not bring attention to their
operations or tactics
senator Mitchell shapin eventually ends
up allowing Ryan to go but it's clear
he's not pleased with the turn of events
no one wants to upset the Venezuelan
government due to their relationship
already being on a knife's edge and
there's a real sense of the characters
having to operate in the shadows in
order to bring things to the light the
plot this time doesn't really revolve
around stopping a terrorist or defusing
a ticking time bomb and instead season
two Caesar I getting involved in an
election that will topple the government
thing that the CIA have been accused of
in the past it's quite a smart move and
whilst initially it was theorized that
the second season would follow the
events of simple fears the 8th episode
run pushes in a different direction that
due to its nature feels unpredictable TV
shows and movies are just so full of the
same situations involving the same
countries and this is a refreshing take
that massively grants the show with a
side that we don't often see Ryan
himself also starts the season vastly
different to how he was in the first run
and he begins as a lecturer teaching
foreign policy to aspiring agents
however he has been monitoring Venezuela
and after bringing it to the attention
of his superiors that he believes Russia
is selling weapons at the country he is
tasked with moving in to investigate
further under the cover of diplomacy
Ryan visits the country and sees just
how poverty-stricken it is what it does
is push the narrative that the
government there is indeed greedy and
neglects its people this not only gets
you invested in the plight of the people
but also the narrative of the show which
is taking those in power down mirroring
this investigation is Korea who has also
been monitoring the movements of
Venezuela and he's quickly thrown back
into the mix with Jack as the two work
together to take down the dictatorship
in the country season 2 definitely feels
more focused than the prior entry and it
doesn't mess about I'm looking at you
drone pilot subplot this is a very
focused run and it gets you more
invested in Ryan who feels like a fully
fleshed out character this time that
Krasinski has been allowed to make his
own previously I feel like he had to
conform to the traditional depictions
but here he gets more free-range the
subject matter at hand also provides a
comment on modern-day politics and in
the same way that Russia is rumored to
have been involved in the most recent US
elections there's a real sense to the
piece as to whether Ryan should really
be doing all of this or if governments
should just mind their own business
they end up backing the dictator
president Reyes is political rival
Gloria banal day someone that wants to
bring democracy to the country and
provide a quote unquote honest election
as an audience member was really left a
question if this was actually an honest
election and the show does a great job
of reminding us that politics is well
always going to be politics whilst Reyes
is clearly
a bad guy there are also additional
villains such as an assassin played by
Tom West Kanishka I've definitely just
butchered his name so I'm very sorry now
you might remember him from Game of
Thrones in which he played the faceless
man and similar to that portrayal he
brings a real air of intelligence and
darkness with him Tom West was slavka I
don't know I'll stop it the guy just
seems like he was born to play
Assassin's like this and he does an
incredible job of providing an
understated foe for Ryan to go up
against I always felt like the Suleiman
stola limelight a bit in the first
season but this time round all of the
villains of the piece of balance Ryan
complimenting him instead of detracting
in the first episode he launches an
attack against Ryan & Co and it's a
really enthralling scene that feels like
it was ripped straight out of a Bourne
movie the assassin perfectly paints
himself out as a real threat and it lets
you know that Venezuela is definitely
worth keeping a closer eye on Jack loses
an ally early on and really has to get
his head in the game for the season
which is more underhanded than the prior
entry Reyes denies orchestrating the
attack and after being allowed to remain
in the country due to the wake of it
Jack infiltrates a jungle compound with
a special ops team headed up by Matisse
it's one of the high points of the
season and it's here that Ryan discovers
chemicals and they end up losing a
soldier behind enemy lines which ends up
being a great subplot that's tense and
feels like an enthralling way to take
the show it's also at this point that he
comes face to face with a mercenary
played by the mummy and this ties into
the ending of the series it gradually
escalates as the show goes on and it has
flashes of the film lone survivor which
definitely is not a bad thing Ryan takes
a trip to London and manages to catch up
with the assassin who was killed by a
spy played wonderfully by Noomi Rapace
and upon returning to Venezuela Reyes
captures both Jack and Greer revealing
that he knows who they are
he accuses the US government of
tampering in the election and when it
looks like banal Dae has a real chance
of taking down his regime the villain
really begins to play his hand the US
Embassy is bombarded with mobs and
evacuated leading Greer and Ryan to defy
orders and go off the grid Reyes calls a
snap election and Greer is betrayed and
captured
enlisting the help of chief of the CIA
in Venezuela Mike November Jack does
whatever it takes to get his friend back
he returns to the jungle camp that he
infiltrated earlier in the show and
recruits the mercs from there in order
to rescue Greer and other political
prisoners from a camp located deep in
the jungle
Reyes orders for them to be executed
after America brings down one of the
country's unregistered satellites and
Ryan and Cole move on the soldiers mid
execution at the camp but they
discovered that Greer has been relocated
to the presidential house as writing and
the capital intensifies here they find
Matisse's his body who was killed
earlier in the season and things really
heat up it leads to a great finale that
clearly has desperation on both sides
with the president on the back foot and
Jack at his wits end trying to bring a
close to the conflict without completely
destabilized the country
Reyes is a really cutthroat man
literally and he kills his right hand
and also fixes the results of the polls
in order to retain power Jack leaks
images of executions in the camps to
news sites and this ends up leading the
people of the country to turn on their
government Jack and Mike head to the
residents to get Correa personally and
they go Rainbow six on these punks and
yet it doesn't disappoint there's a real
closing of the loop here with a special
ops team getting revenge for matisse and
Ryan taken on the President himself
however Mike stops him from killing the
country's leader at the last second due
to the political ramifications that it
would carry in the end though the people
of Venezuela stormed the president's
home and banal day is officially elected
after the results of the Democratic vote
are revealed which gives some hope that
Venezuela finally has a chance they
reunite her with her husband who was a
political prisoner and one of races
captives
this leaves Jack and Greer to return to
the US with the latter announcing that
he is stepping down from field work the
season has a real toll on the character
but in the end he decides to take a step
back now whether he will remain in this
position or not is up for debate but if
we look at the source material Korea
eventually gets promoted to the position
of deputy director of the CIA and I can
imagine that in the third season this is
where the character will progress to he
obviously has a close friendship with
Jack and this will help to improve the
access to equipment that the care
has in the future Jack returns to
Washington stating that though they got
Reyes he thinks that they missed
something when investigating Reyes is
shell company
Cinco Palmer's they discovered that he
only owned half of the company and the
other half was owned by an American
associate Ryan reveals that he has
tracked everything back to senator
shapen and shape and deliberately funded
Venezuela due to a fear of China
overtaking the US but they had less
competition and thus he has been
providing them in order to build their
government and give America an ally
should things come to it shapin states
that if he sweeps this under the rug
that Ryan will be able to run for
Congress
but Ryan declines it and walks away into
a future where there's one less corrupt
soul in the government and one more good
one in a country that sorely needs it
but what did I think of the season
overall well Jack Ryan
indeed builds upon the first season in
many interesting ways toning things back
slightly simplifying the narrative and
therefore making for a far more engaging
story this feels like the season that
the first one should have been and they
get many elements including Jack's
depiction right this time around there's
action drama and a two-sided nature to
the narrative that perfectly reflects
the society that we live in by having
the characters operate in shades of gray
instead of black and white
Amazon also filmed the entire show in
Ultra HD with HDR that has been given to
all Prime members without the need to
pay extra like how you do on Netflix
this allows the show to look incredible
and the skydive scene in the third
episode of the coast of Venezuela that
looks absolutely stunning with it being
a relatively quiet weekend at the cinema
and not much else on Netflix I'd
definitely recommend that you check this
out this weekend as at just eight
episodes it's a really easy watch that
provides a fun time for the viewer this
delivers exactly what I wanted from Jack
Ryan and it gets an 8 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Jack Ryan season 2 and what
you took from the show what do you hope
to see next time and do you agree with
my school comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of this
weekend's other big release doctors
sleep which will be linked at the end go
over everything that you need to know
about the film as well as its ending so
it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
Twitter at definition YT or head over to
my discord server which you'll be linked
in the description below those are the
best ways to keep up to date with all
the latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box on blu-ray
which contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming and Ragnarok and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Jack Ryan in the comments
section below the one is gonna be chosen
the 15th of November and the Cell be
shipped out from the intima gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you